بدايه اليوم من عالم الوظائف والموظفين
وبالتحديد من اولئك الذين وجدوا حين لخداع
شركاتهم بطرق مختلفه واخرها خدعه المعرفه
عنوان هذه الخدعه السوشيال ميديا فمع
اهتمام المدراء ومسؤوليه الموارد البشريه
بما يشاركه الموظف على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي اتجه البعض لهذه الوسيله للحصول
على ترقيه الموضوع سهل وبسيط ويكشفه خبراء
الذكاء الاصطناعي الذين وجدوا ان اكثر من
نصف هذه المقالات المنشوره لا يقراها
ناشرها ولا يتم فتحها اساسا قبل نشرها
الموظفون يعتبرون ان ما ينشرونه سيكون
دليلا على معرفتهم وذكائهم وبحسب خبراء
فانهم يتبعون هذه الطريقه وافضلهم ربما
اولئك الذين يقراون عده اسطر من المقال
دون ان يكملوها لكن لماذا يشارك الموظفون
ما لا يقرؤون سنعرف ذلك مع الزميل لميس
السؤال الاهم اذا لماذا يشارك الموظفون
مقالات لم يقراوها والاجابه كالتالي في
دراسه بريطانيه اجريت في عام 2022 اكدت ان
الناس يربطون المشاركه بالمعرفه بمعنى
انهم يعتقدون ان سلوك المشاركه الخاص بهم
يشكل توقعات الاخرين فيما يتعلق بما
يعرفونه الدراسه تشير الى ان الناس
يعتقدون بفكره الربح بنقره واحده فالفعل
البسيط كمشاركه مشاركه شيء معرفي ما على
صفحاتهم تجعل الاخرين ينظرون اليهم على
انهم اكثر درايه الباحثون اشار الى ان
الناس ما زالوا يعتقدون ان الاخرين يعرفون
ما يشاركونه حتى لو لم يقرا هؤلاء شيئا من
مشاركوها عبر صفحاتهم في مواقع التواصل
وينسى الكثيرون ان ما يشاركه الناس في بعض
الاحيان هو مجرد اشاره الى الاهتمام او
حتى مجرد اشاره الى الرغبه في ان يبدو
مهتمين او حتى مهمين
[موسيقى]
ليث بدايه اريد اسالك شو هو المحتوى او
المقالات اللي انت تحب تشاركها على
السوشيال ميديا
كنت شاركت مره بمقال واندمت شلته لان
اكتشفت بفرنسا كان مقال له علاقه بالحياه
الاجتماعيه بفرنسا وشلت واكتشفت انه فيك
كان مزيف كان يعني شويه شغل عليه فرجعت
للصور انا دايما على الانستغرام مشهور انه
دائما صور بالسوشيال ميديا خصوصا انستقرام
انت
[موسيقى]
لها علاقه بالبزنس او
الاخبار بس اكون قارئتها يعني اكيد مش
مش يعني حطيتها بس اعتباطا بس حلوه فكره
الترقيه خلينا ناخذ الضيف الدائم لصباح
العربيه من جده ينضم الينا مستشار تطوير
الاعمال
عفوا صباح الخير انت دائما متعود على دين
السهام عندك اليوم ليث سمر نعتذر منك ههه
اهلا وسهلا بالعكس
حب مباشره ههه استاذ تراب يعني نلاحظ
كثيرا ان من يشارك خبرا عالميا بغض النظر
ان كان سعيدا عن زواج احد المشاهير او
وفاه ايقونه عالميه يبحث دائما على ان
يكون من الاوائل في نشره وكانه اصبح وكاله
انباء او قناه العربيه او صباح العربيه هل
هذا الفعل يقيم حقا الشخص مهنيا واجتماعيا
يعني للاسف
الدماء تتصدر الانباء الاشياء اللي فيها
اكشن وفيها مخاوف فيها شيء احيان يخوف
الناس اذا في ناس تتسابق كانها بتقول لهم
انتبهوا ترى لكم الخبر حصل موقف اجتماعي
احد الاصدقاء نشر خبر وفاه احد رجال
الاعمال والمسؤولين بعدين اكتشفنا ان
الرجل جاءته جلطه ولا زال حي فيعني كان
موقف محرج جدا بالنسبه له موقف فاجع جدا
بالنسبه لاقربائه وحط هذا الانسان في موقف
محرج خلينا نقول مثلا النقطه الاهم هي
اسمها تحقق يعني ايلون ماسك مثلا ليش هو
اغنى رجال العالم وبحقق هذه الانجازات
الكبيره لسببين هو
ينفذ ما يقرا وهذا فيها وعد الهي من عمل
بما علم اتاه الله اورثه الله علم ما لم
يعلم هذا الانسان بيطلع باشياء الناس
يقولوا هذا جينيس هذا مختلف هذا انسان
يطبق ما يفعل فقط الميزه الثانيه في ايلون
ماسك التحقق شفت ليس التجربه الشخصيه اللي
انت سويتها
نشرت حاجه وطلعت فيك يقول الناس يجوني
السوشيال ميديا حاطين بوست على مقالات
وعلى اشياء ويقول يدعي انه اشياء كثير
سواها في المقابله الشخصيه اسالوا اتش
لماذا واين وكيف ومتى ومن الا ما يخطئ لو
كان كاذب حتجي تقول له ليش عملتها كيف
عملتها مين كان معك كم اخذ منك وقت ايش
الاهم اهم اجابه ايش النتائج العوائد كم
حققت كم خفضت من المصاريف كم حققت من
الايرادات ايش العائد علي في هذا الموضوع
يعني هل تعتقد اليوم في خصوصا على منصات
مثل وتويتر هناك الكثير من يشارك هذه هل
تعتقد انه هذا فعلا يعني حضرتك مستشار في
تطوير الاعمال هل تعتقد انه هذا فعلا يؤثر
على قرار المدراء على الاقل لاعطاء فرصه
يعني يمكن مثل ما قلت انت تسال الاسئله
الخمسه بعد بس مبدئيا هل يؤثر فعلا على
اعطاء فرصه لاجراء المقابله
ممكن ممكن جدا تسير انا بس تعطي معلومات
ثانيه برضو 90% من الناس يقراوا الشابتر
الاول من الكتاب تلاقيه عنده مكتبه كامله
وحطلك اياها وراه وجيبها وهو ما تاخذ فيها
اي قرار ممكن يكسب الفرصه انه تجري مع
المقابله لكن الذكاء هنا اني اتاكد احيانا
يكونوا من نفس الموظفين اللي موجودين امس
حصل حادثه معينه احد الاشخاص اتصل فيا
يقول لي عندنا
في كل اجتماع عنده قدره
على لدرجه انه نقول معلومات خاطئه والناس
تصدقوا ياخذوه في اكثر من لجنه يضعوا فيها
فهذه مصيبه كبيره جدا اهم نقطه احد اكبر
شركات التطوير القياده ايش اللي تعمله
تعمل حاجه اسمها حطوا سيستم اي شيء تتعلمه
في ناس يدخلوا كورسات ويحط انا اخذت
يعني موثقه او مثبته في
الشركه هذا ايش تعمل اي شيء تتعلمه يقول
لك كيف حتنفذوا في العمل ايش الخطوات اللي
حتعملها وايش العوائد المتوقعه وما يسيبك
بعد شهر يرجع يتابع معاه يقول لك ايش سويت
كم نتائج حققتها وما يتركها الا لما يوافق
او يوافقها المدير
برايك هل هناك شريحه مهنيه او فئه عمريه
تمارس هذا السلوك اي يعني نشر معلومات دون
التعمق بمحتوى
والله للاسف هي شاعت بين كل الفئات سواء
اشخاص ما يكونوا مطلعين لكن يبغوا يظهروا
زي ما تفضلت انهم في مظهر المطلع يبغى
يكون من ضمن الفئه هذه احيانا يكونوا
مسؤولين احيانا يكونوا اشخاص في مراكز
قياديه الجميل في الموضوع انه مثلا كان
احد الرجال الاعمال المعروفين يتكلم عن
نظام العمل
وكلفته الحكومه برئاسه وزاره العمل كان
ينشر مقالاته ويقترح اقتراحات مثل وزير مع
الوزير الراجحي الان هو مثال تطبيقي
لتطبيق ما يفعل ومكان يقترح ويقرا نفذوا
على ارض الواقع شفنا النتائج
نعم
جزيلا لانضمامك الينا